this is nightmare hospital yeah Shikari
oh um shit became real literally arms
the base got together the ice is gonna
break and formed a walking dead scenario
um by the way um mother bad doctor worst
doctor ever much talk about as good a
doctor as she has a mother I didn't
realize when I took this person's pulse
fed they're nothing but a giant mass of
arms that's my other primal thing this
is a chi accent yeah I don't wonder how
she can get a giant sword in a duffel
bag yeah oh my god the size of that
sword that was like fucking cloud sword
give our final fantasy I just take all
that stuff as cartoon cousin it's a
giant sword honestly we'll Bob would be
a little bit more about it and I don't
just like this episode but what bothered
me a little bit is like just two minutes
in it's like okay this is the lesson and
we're gonna dwell on this for a while
and oh I can do this myself
oh you came I did you hear that mother
say no no whoa no again just like to
quote Bad Santa they all can't be
winners kids can't all be what there's
still a lot of good stuff in the episode
um it's more just sort of the well and
even the end where they come together
it's like okay we made some progress and
I really like Steven looking down at
that sword when she's connecting with it
there was very nice scene there was
somebody on yeah there was something a
little too I guess broadcasted like the
morale and everything like when they hug
it's like I love you too honey I just
remember Terry I was like oh like it
just it felt like three like the funny
thing is the show is so good I kind of
like doing this sort of thing normally
that in what would just be any normal
episode of any other show yeah this
feels somehow rehearsed and kind of try
it like which is not a criticism of the
show doll it's just it's amazing how
high this show set the bar then just
doing something that I would see in any
other cartoon I'm like
the status quo is a status' low for this
show I think you status blow those we're
poets and we do know it blow it so um no
there's a lot of I got excited for this
episode because when you see them go
into that hospital they cut the music
that thing's just moving the the colors
the angles it's a scary setup I was
actually like this like nothing's
happened yeah crazy pretty intense
I thought the two patients the gem
shards were pretty scary yeah uh and
when they started when they actually
come alive and they start I think up to
when it starts slamming against the door
that's why I stopped being scary when
you finally see em it's like and they
are scary we first see him and then it's
okay now it's a Steven universe episode
after that where the build-up to it
seemed like something else
uncle horror film like the colors and
the angles and the shadows and stuff and
like some lack of music or even just the
tiny little sound effects one really
interesting how could she now no I'm
just
worst Hospital ever I show up and I'm a
mass of nothing but legs and 12 eyeballs
and then just like yeah no pulse guess
I'm just gonna leave this patient here
in stupid hospital equipment I'm like
that's you're worried I'm gonna take a
walk yes to say there's another staff
account stethoscope somewhere in that
room she doesn't have to go that far out
to another mile of it because like she
never lifts the blanket up but at the
same time who does that who keeps
somebody entirely covered with it but
why does I know she did look at a vagina
I don't think this is a car accident
where would she would check the hurt I'd
say it was a car accident if the body
were dead and not moving but it's like
Bagram forever I'm like what if it has
no mouth how can it make sounds I do not
want to
oh I have no mother but 12 arms and I
must scream cards in it I I mean that's
that's cartoons to me I mean I'm just
sort of like whatever you know it's like
why do peridot not punch Steven but
instead go you know I need a hammer
effect never get sick in Beach City I
don't want to say very clear-eyed the
one thing it does kind of bring up is
that okay these gems are there they know
that there's this cassimy crop a few
episodes ago uh why aren't more people
educating themselves about how they work
and what they are instead cuz you know
if they would just listen to the fucking
theme so have a good idea that we are
the crystal gym so that is the one thing
I'm like okay that's the one cat
illegitimate hole I'm like I don't get
unless it's just part of it like oh I
just want to be separately well serviced
it's obviously because mayor Dewey wrote
the whole history so there's nothing to
see here sirs just just go along and
then go about your own business um yeah
I felt like if they did more of this as
me along with all those like if they did
more of the suspense in the horror of
like what you didn't see and sir
creeping in the shadows it didn't have
to emphasize them what that's your
reason because your only alternative
news source is fucking Ronaldo and who
the hell wants to listen to him you just
really want Ronaldo yeah I just even
when he's not in an episode he'll his
presence like it's like Sauron watch it
yeah it's like I can almost see pairs of
beady eyes in the background and certain
CFO Jeff is gonna like wait it's that
one although no somebody just splash
some paint in the layout artwork
Mississippi um I really wanna give
credit to like I said the backgrounds
and those simple shapes I mean a lot of
them were just squares but just the
colors they use and where they place him
and stuff
they're usually yeah where's was really
amazed I die I know it no I don't you're
saying it was very nice and legitimately
creepy like you didn't like Lenny
Bukowski me look like a David Fincher
film what a green going up yeah like if
David Fincher did a totally sleeping
woman oh yeah um lady I think he did did
you not see the social network
yeah nobody talked trying that movie
they're all zombies right isn't that how
it worked uh but well i seven i think
again account that's not true and that's
why if we count serial killers is horror
and yeah kevin spacey is very scary just
normal just normal yeah um when there's
something about when you can put someone
in a really bright well-lit room and
it's still creepy and it's still scary i
like and when they're in like we're
doing right now yeah so we're just like
that's a scary enough um but when you
see them in that room and there's the
low sheet is the movement you just see
the arm hanging there and stuff and it's
quiet and it's it's not only lit it's
like over lit i mean so it's still just
a little uncomfortable and i like i like
when it's like they don't always have to
rely on the dark in the shadows
obviously it's really good to help it
help i do though that it's a hospital
because about you hospitals gonna fuck
enemy i don't know they scary but you
don't typically want to be in lungs i do
something wrong
yeah it's like you're only there if
you're sick you're dying or somebody
else you know is sick more dying or
you're dead so such like a boy you're
dead sitting in the way yeah so I just
we need a patch Adams in the hospital
nobody's nobody's happy in a hospital
the only people ever happy in a hospital
or is if you've just given birth or
something even a happy while you're
doing that it's only afterwards like I
guess I worked out I'm really not
against the patch Adams the real patch
Adams out the bullshit movie version
idea of how to do hospitals he wants to
make them very positive happy places cuz
he feels the patients would get better
faster and they've done tests and they
do I mean it's not a bad idea
well there's no way to go about doing it
coming around to that a lot of the new
hospitals I've seen that have been
designed we said they built in this area
have all like earth tones and greens and
it's got like a Zen quality where's like
some of the old house holes it's then
like the tile
Gerald whitey tile where it's just see
with all the white you can see all the
blood splotches better you see there's a
reason they said horror films in
hospitals Allahu Allah
spells in horror films it's it's they're
scary places and yeah I'm down with all
the white tile looks like a White Castle
which is pretty much that's what same
thing is out of me um did she call white
dungeon that's what really that's just
torture yeah sorry Brad
you're insane Oh Oh all right it's okay
Michael it'll give out 45 but you know
what it will be a life well worth living
oh do I have the age that you are but
I'll die happy but I would like a slow
die old and like in your 90s but you'll
be sad and a shriveled up husk i
meanwhile will have died eating my 1
million words the barium like in a giant
white castle a container like those
little fox
oh no Berryman just bury me in the grave
case boy friends is your motive
Elzy because there's always gonna be
that one Bruce is like you many people
know they're gonna send it to brand me
did you see what they said about it was
like crave case that's amazing amazing
yes just put a net my will just just
burn me in the crave case we'll make it
a cremation let's scatter my ashes over
another White Castle no you would take
with love to my body put in between
White Castle buds and if you want you
may consume me but yeah this got scary
like the episode all ties back white
castles and scary hospitals have this
great big connection um that Brad should
be nowhere near any of them because god
knows what he's gonna do in any of them
right on great and Rea sexy how do we
decide oh why we decided to make this a
big breath um but cuz we mentioned my
castle at all it's like it has to go
back to me you just go back to our dad
because he loves White Castle he's
obsessed I think Brad may put our dad to
shame yeah no he dad doesn't have any
White Castle merchandise no well we did
live in Seattle he did go and get the
ones at the store
Rene white castle's in Seattle they're
the ones you had to microwave and you
think why castles bad tried microwave my
cat oh no I think Brad likes that's too
much I don't know I they can't tell the
difference I ain't steamed in the
plastic you don't get it I don't you
take the plastic off if I just eat it
all the plastic has more nutritional
value
that's how I get my Gucci that's how I
get my protein that's from the plastic I
don't get it from the beat all right
then the next episode Brad tries plastic
so wow that's up sorry Brad um but
anything else we got on this episode
Brad's gonna watch is just right yeah
yeah it's pretty true um they left out
my love of Taco Bell yeah that's what'll
upset him suits
what no fuckin Crystal Pepsi they're
assholes
no shadow Taco Bell um but uh good
episode uh not dumb I'm gonna back yeah
I mean it's it's fine I guess I wouldn't
say it's like a bad episode by any means
it may be like the lesson a little
standard um and I think I'll use it with
any other episode any other show if you
like whatever that status quo but for
them the status quo is like it is kind
of below what they're usually doing I
just just remember where we were because
we both thought the same thing after she
goes through that whole sword fight in
the to gem gem shards are in the balls
and it cuts to the mother we just want
to skip just one see the mother oh maybe
they know them okay um so I'm having a
good lesson and some good suspense it I
mean it's fine
um it's I think you could cut that moron
great lessons whenever your mom says
don't sword fight sword fight yeah I
mean basically I mean come on we want
create
Tiger kids I feel like that's an 80s
lesson yeah so much movies like Goonies
and all these other things like don't do
that okay we're doing that
and guess what it worked out great it
don't do that I'll do it online oh I'm
so exciting on tumblr well I love what
you talk about I control everything
about her like her study time I know
what she does on the internet I was just
like and by the way your surf history is
disgusting no one needs to see Justin
Beiber doing that nobody um I I think
it's good to end on Justin Bieber doing
that and we can leave it open to
whatever that is but I won't do that so
um thanks for watching and let your
imaginations take flight on that take
care
pleasant dreams thing about Justin
Bieber and White Castle